avec nous ce soir dominique lapointe
économiste principal à valeurs
mobilières banque laurentienne bonsoir
dominique lapointe
est ce qu'on se dirige vers une eau
selon vous de 50 points de base un demi
point de pourcentage de 13 avril
c'est bien possible je voudrais qu'en ce
moment c'est vraiment comme des
libérations mais que vous avez mentionné
le sous gouverneur christie le ouvert la
porte dans son discours vendredi dernier
puis en fait elle a fait écho au
président avec le fédéral ne vont pas au
qu'il y avait une manière plus explicite
suggéré qu'ils étaient prêtes à aussi
les taux de 50 points de base lorsqu'on
fait s'y connaissent en danger cette
fois ça peut être plusieurs
pubs et la cie si on le fait on le
ferait le 13 avril est ce qu on pourrait
même le faire le 1er juin deux réunions
de suite
mais si on regarde que ce que les
marchés financiers s'attendent en ce
moment pour le nombre de hausses de taux
à terme de pourcentage à la fin de
l'année ça serait ce genre de scénario
là où on devait de lausanne ou pas
nécessairement consécutive mais de
zahrani ou en allemand de 50 points de
base une ambulance qu'est ce qui a
changé par rapport au mois de décembre
contre ces discussions le sait qu'on
observe à plus long terme une
augmentation des attentes
inflationnistes des ménages et des
entreprises qui fait créneau banque
centrale la fameuse spirale
déflationniste pour être évité et donc
qu'est ce que est ce que 50 points de
base
sa sa frappe l'inflation tout à coup
qu'est ce que ça change un demi point de
pourcentage
pour mentionner aussi c'est l'amplitude
qui changent et c'est aussi le taux
d'intérêt finales auxquelles
correspondent donc on pense qu'on
pourrait aussi augmenter les taux en
bowling à un niveau plus élevé qu'on
passait auparavant en fait ce qu'il faut
enseigner c'est que on réfère toujours à
un certain taux directeur à un niveau
neutre pour l'économie dont c'est à dire
une fois qu'on a un taux directeurs en
ce moment il est à 2 25% environ le taux
longs est-il que la banque du canada eux
n'est pas entré de stimuler l'économie
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec les cinq ans
one bale c'est qu'on se rapproche plus
rapidement le de ce taux où
l'économie n'est plus stimulée et même
aux états unis on parle beaucoup devenir
un monte de tous ses records en eau du
tourneur ce qui va vraiment ralentir
l'économie plus rapidement alors là on
est à au canada le taux directeurs 0,5
vous dit qu'on irait jusqu'à 2 est-ce
qu'on irait jusqu'à 2,25 pour cent d'ici
la fin de l'année et en fait c'est ce
qui est attendu dans les marchés
financiers mais je pense qu'on est
tendre une rivale lui à la banque du
canada certainement on va aller plus
vite que ce qui était attendu
nous on avait dit trois autres sans
mettre certainement de hand sur un
scénario qui serait crédible ce serait
d'avoir l'équivalent de 0 25 point de
base
parrino d'ici la fin de l'année donc
c'est possible qu'on ait de 0.5 pour ça
pendant ce temps leur mais on passe
encore que les conditions financières
vont réagir assez fortement il y avoir
une réaction de marché est-ce qui va
peut-être permettre à la banque du
canada de prendre une pause
éventuellement et d'évaluer comment
l'endettement réagi comment le marché
hypothécaire réagi le pétrole semble
avoir atteint une forme de plafond au
cours des derniers jours on se promène
110 entre 100 et 120 dollars disons cela
comme ça forte chute aujourd'hui quelle
lecture vous faites du marché du pétrole
en ce moment
le marché du pétrole depuis le début de
l'invasion russe en ukraine suis
vraiment les grands aller au delà galles
c'est à dire qu'en fait j'avais l'envié
une nouvelle comme quoi la russie
pourrait concentrer son offensive sur le
dôme basque sur une forme de stratégie
quand même temps l'ukraine qui réaffirme
être qu'à négocié une forme de
neutralité militaire
tout à l'eprus a négocié le futur de ces
régions là dans le thalys un impression
d'optimisme aux marchés du pétrole aux
marchés boursiers ici qui pense qu'on
pourra avoir un cessez le feu plus
rapidement mais je sais qu'à chaque
nouvelle positive au point du conflit on
va en limousine qui négocient donc c'est
très volatile en ce moment faire
attention est-ce que ce conflit là
cependant pourrait selon votre
estimation être moins important que
prévu sur la croissance économique
mondiale
ont nécessairement en fait il ya une
importance très importante au
l'économie européenne puis on l'avait
dit dès le départ le canada et les états
unis nous relations directes avec la
russie sont assez minimes c'est vraiment
au point de vue de l'impact indirect au
point de vue delà de l'impact sur la
consommation
aussi on a réussi c'est le feu c'est un
scénario optimiste encore pour l'instant
et que les prix du pétrole et d'autres
qui pensent je descendais donc on
pourrait relancer à parler de pic pour
l'inflation dans les mois à venir et
l'impact sur la consommation des ménages
l'impact sur la confiance des
entreprises est moins mais pour
l'instant ils sont tellement volatil et
incertain et difficile à dire vraiment
qu'est ce qui va arriver au point de vue
n'est pas qu'économique au final et on
surveille toujours les chaînes
d'approvisionnement notamment le
confinement en chine
ouais c'est le civil qui tombe pour le
malheureusement les chaînes de
production mondiale la politique de zéro
crever de rancennes qui semble bien
fonctionner au départ tandis qu'en ce
moment on ne le varia micron qui
beaucoup plus contagieux semble avoir un
effet plus important sur la contagion à
chiots nés ont décidé de reconfirmer
shanghai qui environ 5% du pib chinois
dans le cénacle voilà il ya des usines
qui vont fermer pendant quelques jours
ils savent aussi credo télé dans la
chaîne d'approvisionnement hausse après
vente transport donc vraiment à un effet
boule de neige au point de vue la
pression sur leurs frontières merci pour
cette analyse dominique lapointe merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
oh